attention fellow gamers after years of
trying Hollywood has finally done
something right for us Scott Pilgrim vs.
that all right so Michael Cera plays
Scott Pilgrim a 22 year old socially
awkward guy who starts dating this girl
but in order to actually date her he has
to defeat her seven evil exes hey man we
have all been there and then the comedic
dating romance an onslaught of video
game awesomeness ensues now from the
trailer you can tell if this movie's
filmed to be stylish like a video game
like imagine a video game an anime had a
kid together that kid would be Scott
Pilgrim vs. the world the movie I mean
the social parody of the dating world is
portrayed in this movies enough to make
me laugh but the fact that this movie
has videogame isms thrown in there makes
it the very definition of Awesome
tacular I'll break it down to you like
this do you like video games The Legend
of Zelda specifically anime DBZ video
game music and sound effects and you
find the dating scene frustrating to a
laughable degree if you said yes to two
or more of those you'll probably like
Scott Pilgrim vs. the world they should
sound like an infomercial this movie's
like a throwback to the Super Nintendo
generation of video games yeah not Xbox
its Nintendo and for you Xbox users they
did make a movie for you this weekend
and the flights in this movie the fights
were awesome some of them were a little
anticlimactic and how they ended but it
was still DBZ SoCal Street Fighter
awesomeness and the comedic timing was
really good too it was like a cartoon so
you really got to suspend your disbelief
so when someone goes from one outfit to
the other in the blink of an eye let's
roll with it now I will say that the
biggest letdown in this movie was one
fight in particular one fight was gonna
be so awesome you see this moment you're
like dude this is the coolest thing that
I have ever seen this is the best movie
ever seriously you're having like a
nerdgasm at this point this is gonna be
the coolest fight since the first time
you unlocked Akuma and the fight just
never happens shame on you guys for the
bait and switch
not you guys I mean damn guys the rest
of the movie is absolutely awesome it's
like what would happen if DiCaprio and
his crew went three layers deep into my
dreams safe to say I like what I saw and
this is the nerd tastic movie that we've
all been waiting for as a subscriber of
mine phrased it to me I'm in lesbians
with this movie well said Daniela well
said Scott Pilgrim vs. the world may not
be for everybody but I thought they'd
mix the videogame anime and awesome
really well and if the thought of that
mixture makes you hyped
why you still here right now go watch it
but you know if the movie doesn't start
for like an hour or so and you want some
free entertainment then click right here
to see more
[Music]